all right let's uh let's get started so
welcome everyone to the Simon Institute
uh my name is wenat guruswami I'm a
senior scientist here at the Simons uh
Institute and it's my great pleasure to
invite you all uh to the boot camp of
the program on data structures and
optimization for fast algorithms as you
all I'm sure no Simons Institute is a
leading international venue for
collaborative research in TCS and
related areas it was established in 2012
with a generous uh Grant from the Simons
Foundation which continues to support us
uh very generously The Institute
convenes the world's leading researchers
in the theory of computing and related
fields as well as the next generation of
outstanding young scholars and the main
programming here is thematic semester
programs but we also run a lot of
workshops and summer clusters and The
Institute also engages in many Outreach
activities to popularize algorithmic
thinking broadly in science Humanities
and Engineering so this week um we kick
off the activities for this fall
semester program on data structures and
fast algorithms for optimization with
the boot camp the boot camp is always as
intended to acquaint program
participants with the key themes of the
programs it'll consist of five days of
tutorial presentations on a variety of
topics related to the program from
leading experts and a real sincere
thanks to the organizers of the program
who are also the organizers of this boot
camp so so um who are Alina in here
Monica henzinger um yint Le jalani
Nelson and Aaron sford so maybe a round
of applause for
them so as always all talks here are
live streamed on YouTube and are
recorded for posting on the Simon's
website where they enjoy a life and
impact uh long after the boot camp winds
down and in particular I want to mention
the boot camp talks in particular have
served as a really valuable resource for
you know students and young researchers
and anyone else trying to learn the
field worldwide to learn about the key
results of a topic in a carefully
curated form so so I know some of you
the speakers are working hard some of
you are speaking all day and so on but
rest assured that it's really worth the
effort because your talks will have a
long life um and be very worth it and
particularly for this topic where you
know progress has been happening at a
frenetic Pace with you know such
remarkable breakthroughs I think it's
really really we are all looking forward
to outcomes of this food Camp so some
logistical things before I hand over to
Aaron um food is provided before the
first talk and uh during the breaks for
lunch you're all on your own but there
are many options walking uh distance um
and we any we ask that you please leave
all food and drinks outside before you
come into the auditorium so it helps us
keep the auditorium clean and if you
need to leave your stuff when you go for
lunch or elsewhere there are lockers in
the backside of the room which very easy
to use and uh we have our videographer
om far who will help you with any AV
issues uh during the talks and um so
finally I want to give a special round
of thanks to Elizabeth Yen who was the
events person organizing all the
logistics uh for this week's event and
as well as this program going forward
thanks
Elizabeth and uh so now with that I'll
hand over things to Aaron who will give
a sort of sort of a detail welcome and
intro to this
proam all right thank you very much for
the introduction hello everyone good
morning I am so glad you all made it
here I am really excited uh that this
program is starting um as was introduced
I am Aaron sidford I am one of the main
organizers of the program along with the
the rest of this team of organizers uh
that vot just introduced um so um before
um you should have all probably been
receiving a many of you should have been
receiving a welcome email from me if you
haven't already please reach out um and
before I get into we get into all the
tutorials for the day um what I wanted
to do is take this talk to kind of
introduce the program a bit more broadly
before going into the more technical
tutorial talks on each of the kind of
main focuses of the program I wanted to
take some time here and talk about the
motivations of the program set the stage
for all of these talks and have you all
have a sense of kind of what's bringing
this program together and what we'll be
uh doing for the some of the things that
we'll be doing for the next many months
so let's start at the beginning like
what is this program about why are we
here um this is kind of a a broad
question I know many you here for a
number of different reasons and there's
a lot of different motivations to
participate in the workshop um whatever
they are I just quick thank you again to
the Simons Institute for making this
program possible and and um letting it
happen so um what I want to talk about
is maybe one sort of broad motivation
for this program in particular one thing
that's motivating it happen so I think
there's a lot of particular reasons this
program and workshop is rather timely
one of the many motivations for having
it now though has to do with a certain
Suite of algorithmic advances that have
happened over the last decade so one of
the key motivations for this program is
over you know the last decade for a
range of sort of fundamental
foundational optimization and
algorithmic pro problems things ranging
from linear system solving to minimum
cost flow to Computing gumery Hood trees
and this is this is just a small
sampling of the many advances that have
happened over the last decade um and for
many many of these problems there's been
a number of advances in getting provably
efficient algorithms these faster
algorithms in many cases have overcome
decades old barriers that have persisted
for getting fast run times and for many
of these problems not only were there
advances showing you could solve these
problems more efficiently um but in some
of these cases was even shown that for
these problems you can solve them almost
linear and near optimally kind of nearly
closing the door on a number of uh long
lines of research at least when it comes
in terms of obtaining efficient run
times um so this would be maybe enough
for for motivating having some sort of
uh program to talk about all these sort
of amazing advances and see how much
further we can push them um but one of
the key emphases in this program and the
way we decided to structure this program
around these advances has to do with the
fact that many of these results not only
um you know share a commonality in terms
of the types of tools and techniques
that were brought to bear to ultimately
achieve these advances so to get these
faster runtimes um you know
interestingly a number of these results
they were obtained by building upon and
combining sort of a wide range of
algorithmic tools um and the Simons
Institute which is you know has uh uh
been famous for its reputation over the
last many years and bringing together
researchers from a number of different
areas it seemed like having a program on
tying these togethers even further was
was a nice idea so you get a sense of
this you know many of these advances
they build and combine a number of
different algorithmic tools so many of
these results is use a number of
different different optimization methods
things like multiplicative weights or
interior Point methods or gradient
descent they also um used and built upon
different sort of data structures so
things like dynamically maintaining
decompositions of graphs known as
expander decompositions dynamically
maintaining ways of solving certain
sorts of linear systems um dynamically
maintaining um you know a vector
undergoing certain types of implicit
updates and in addition these results
use a variety of different sketching
techniques so things like Johnson lindra
Subspace embeddings and count sketch and
many many more so these results have
been using and building upon sort of a
wide range of uh techniques and to get a
sense of like how these techniques have
been coming together to get these sort
of improvements there's a number of I
think interesting ways that these
results and more have kind of
highlighted surprising connections
between these different areas of
research and different sort of problems
that you might consider maybe you
wouldn't have traditionally considered
in one of these areas but that make a
lot of sense to uh consider when you
consider them in sort of a a broader
algorithm that's using techniques for
all of them so there're many many ways
these different algorithmic tools have
come together um here's just like one
example of a kind of common way these
different algorithmic tools have been
used to get certain sorts of
improvements so here's here's one way
that a number of these results have
worked um they start at a at a very high
level with a difficult optimization
problem that's trying to be solved maybe
solve a line system solve a linear
program commute a minimum cost flow in a
graph at a high level if you look at
some of these algorithms what they're
doing is applying some sort of
optimization method to solve the this
optimiz to solve these difficult
optimization problems and what these
optimization methods do is you can think
of they follow some sort of iterative
procedure that takes this complex uh you
know problem that people have been
trying to improve run times for for deck
grades like minimum cost flow and they
essentially give um results saying you
can Sol solve that problem if you can
solve a certain sequence of sub problems
maybe solve a linear system maybe
multiply a matrix with a vector maybe
compute a tree in the
graph and one way that then uh these
results have been achieving faster
runtimes for solving these problems is
by rather than just designing faster
runtimes for solving sort of the
individual problems like a faster linear
system solver or a faster Matrix Vector
multiply though some do that they treat
this entire sequence of sub problems
that are being solved as a data
structure problem the question of being
able to solve a sequence of linear
systems multiply a sequence of Matrix
vectors and then to ultimately solve
that data structure they you this
problem they use certain sort of
sketching or randomization or sampling
techniques to speed up the implement the
solution to this data structure problem
and then by putting all of these pieces
together uh faster run times have uh
been achieved and this sort of broad uh
template has been followed for a variety
of different methods from um one one one
term that I think might talk a more like
the lassan Paradigm solving certain
graphical linear systems known as llans
they apply certain iterative methods
like Richards generation for solving the
linear system where um certain
decompositions are then uh either data
structures or decompositions are used to
to make implementing the iterations
cheap and like ultimately Computing some
of the decompositions uses certain sorts
of randomization a variety of fast
algorithms for linear programming
semi-definite programming minimum cost
flow you can all kind of explain them in
this broad template in terms of what
optimization method is being used what
are the sequence of sub problems looking
like and what sort of optimization
techniques do you need to solve the data
structure problems and what's I think
been interesting about this template is
it's led to a number of new optimization
methods if you're trying to design
optimization methods to make the data
structure problem simpler that motivates
new problems you might want to solve so
it's given new data structure problems
you'd want to solve new Criterion for
Designing optimization method method and
new sketching techniques you might want
to develop to fit into this
framework um uh it's also given Rises
some interesting themes and sort of
algorithm design um it's it's motivated
wanting to have data structures that you
can Implement even if like the next
round of the um input to the data
structure depends on the previous if you
use these data structures in the loop
you need them to be able to succeed even
um if you know an adversary can see the
output of the data structure a previous
round and so this has made some new
connections between areas um but this is
just one example of how these different
techniques have been combined together
to get some of these algorithmic
advances um here's one other example
that's been kind of fun for certain
problems like um natural Dynamic data
structure problems like Computing a
maximum matching in a bipartite graph um
you could think of the natural Dynamic
problem of wanting to maintain a maximum
matching in a graph um under let's say
Edge deletion so some sequence of
modifications to the graph and there's
been recent work that says well you can
use different results from optimization
Theory to reduce this Dynamic problem to
a sequence of static problems so this
optimization uh Theory results when
analyzed carefully they say if you can
solve certain sorts of regular certain
sorts of um regularized versions of Max
matching or certain sort of regularized
optimization problems well they have
stability properties you can prove such
that if you can solve just that sequence
they naturally are compatible for
solving the dynamic problem more
efficiently in the particular case of uh
maximum matching under graph undergoing
Edge deletion um there's been work
showing you can do this and then in turn
you know this motivates new sorts of um
optimization or graphical optimization
problems you want to solve which in turn
have been solved by the template on the
previous side of using different
optimization methods uh which are then
implemented by solving a data structure
problem using more random sampling so
this is just a two quick examples of I
think the very Rich interplay that's
happened between designing you know
dynamic algorithms for graphs and for
linear algebraic problems designing new
optimization methods and building new
sketching techniques towards getting uh
different sorts of algorithmic results
all right so with all that motivation
aside what's the actual goal for the
program and how are we structuring
things so we have these three main
focuses sort of data structures
optimization and sketching um and the
use of all of these techniques to get
more efficient faster algorithms for
solving foundational problems so one of
the goals to study all of these things
to seek advances in each of these areas
design more efficient algorithms build
new tools of Frameworks um but
particular for emphasis for you know
having this program at the Simons
Institute which I think does a fantastic
job of bringing together researchers
from many different areas is to really
explore the interplay between all these
areas and look for more new robust and
interesting sort of connections between
these different areas of research and
kind of expand and enhance the research
at all of these areas so the goal of the
program beyond the sort of very very
broad goal of improving everything that
falls in this category which is rather
big is to sort of you know look for new
opportunities for collaboration and
research and progress at the boundaries
of these different areas of algorithm
design so that's the very broad goal how
are we actually going to do this or
structure the program well the first
step as you all know is we're going to
have boot camp this week so we'll have a
workshop this week introducing sort of
fundamental tools and techniques in all
of these different areas um at the end
of this week we'll have a town hall um
to discuss how we actually want to
structure the week to week of the
program what sort of seminars and
reading groups and sort of weekly
activities we want to have um in this
broad area of research um we'll then
have a workshop on Dynamic graph
algorithms we'll have a workshop on
sketching and we'll have a workshop on
optimization right so we'll have a
workshop on each of these main areas you
know in light of the sort of different
sort of connections between them that
we're exploring during the
program as for boot camp itself um the
plan for the week um you know is to give
a variety of talks that sort of um give
the fundamental tools and techniques in
each of these areas as well as some of
the sort of common tools and languages
and uh notation and things that might be
helpful for doing research at the
boundary of these different areas um so
after this talk we'll kick things off
with suant talking about graph linear
algebra um a common thing underlying a
number but not all of the results I
mentioned is a way of looking at
different graph optimization problems in
terms of linear algebra and one of the
things that's facilitated for a number
of problems bringing all of these
different tools to Bear is this sort of
linear algebraic view of these graphical
problems and since this is one of the
many sort of foundationals glues between
these different areas of research in
recent years it's what we're going to
start the program with um so that'll be
sushan presenting right after this um
we're then going to continue with this
um afternoon thata start talking about
uh graph data structures one of the main
areas of uh the program and then you
know since a lot of the program will be
structured around getting faster
algorithms for solving all of these
problems and more efficient algorithms
um as we as we know some not every
runtime you might hope to achieve is
always possible um and it's good to know
what to do if you trying to solve one of
these problems for a while are rather
stuck and building off the boot camp
that happened last week we'll have some
talks on conditional hardress and fine
grain complexity so we all have some
common tools and techniques of what to
do should we not actually achieve faster
algorithms or be a little stuck for any
of these problems um we're then going to
have a day of talks on sketching uh uh
followed by a number of different
shorter talks on optimization so we'll
have a few lectures on first order
optimization methods some uh talks on
higher order optimization methods we'll
also talk about data Matrix data
structures that are a natural bridge of
data structure and sort of sketching and
linear algebra and some of these methods
and we'll end the workshop with some
talks on interior Point methods the idea
is when all this complete we're not
necessarily giving talks on the problems
in the intersection but we're giving all
of these tools and techniques that are
being combined in all of these different
ways to get these results so we all have
some common uh I think terminology and
shared experience and all of these
methods for as we continue to talk
together over the course of the program
um before I move on thank you very much
to all the presenters I look forward to
all your talks this week and thank you
very much for for all
volunteering um one thing before I wrap
up and we take a a quick break and then
turn things over to sushan is um one
thing I want to mention is this is all
what I just presented is sort of the
formal structure of the program that's
in place for every single program
there's a sequence of workshops um
there's there's a sequence of workshops
starting starting with a boot camp in
addition to that there are some things
that we're going to organize together
over the course of the program and this
Friday at 11:00 a.m. here we're going to
have a town hall to discuss how we want
to structure the week to week of the
program what things we want to
facilitate you know research and
discussions and collaborations over the
course of the program Beyond these
workshops um we have a lot of freedom
here to coordinate different sorts of
weekly seminars whiteboard talks social
events so we can discuss what we want um
it's up to us what we want to do I'm
looking for volunteers to you know help
organize social events maybe organize a
weekly seminar um the idea is over the
next few days I wanted to mention this
right away so that we can all Talk
Amongst ourselves over the next few days
feel free to talk to me during breaks if
you have any ideas or please if you'd
like to volunteer for any of this um and
I look forward to discussing with all of
you um also just two administrative
notes um there's a mailing list for the
program should have received a welcome
email from me if you're in the program
if you haven't let me know um and suan
kindly set up a zulip we can use uh for
collaborating over the course of the
program so just want to leave those
links there so that's it um thank you
all I can pause for a moment for
questions we'll take a few minutes to to
stretch our legs and then uh I'll turn
over to sashan so thank
[Applause]
you know it's kind of ear early and this
is a kind of broad talk but are there
any
questions if not I have the oh
fantastic all right so let's take five
minutes if people want one more sip of
coffee or a drink or something um we'll
let sushan set up so come back here in
five minutes for the first tutorial
thanks